president Trump's campaign fighting back
hard against the Russia collusion smear
by suing the New York Times for libel
and claiming the liberal papers trying
to influence the outcome of the 2020
election the lawsuits over an op-ed that
claimed there was an overarching deal
between then candidate Trump and Russia
to help him win the 2016 election here's
the president reacting when they get the
opinion totally wrong as the New York
Times did and frankly they've got a lot
wrong over the last number of years so
we'll see how that let that work its way
through the court
it's beyond an opinion that's not an
opinion that's something much more than
an opinion they did a bad thing and
they'll be more coming so Emily this is
after Muller found no collusion this is
after the New York Times reported there
was no collision so the New York Times
runs a column that says there's
basically collusion there's a conspiracy
there's a deal is that libelous if they
know it's wrong and do it anyway right
well we will see in that lawsuit and its
outcome and certainly that's what the
president thinks I think if I were him
in that moment here's what I here's how
I would have said it though it's
basically the basis for that for that
lawsuit I would have said look they are
claiming it's merely an opinion piece
but that being said if you have a
malicious intent and you disregard truth
and diligence and you publish it anyway
and you know it to be false and you know
it's gonna hurt their reputation and it
did in fact cause damage because you
have to prove actual damages it did in
fact cause damage to my campaign and
that is why we were seeming that is why
we are suing so that's what I would have
said in that moment but um I think the
issue here will be whether in fact there
were impact of all damages at this point
however it's simply an echo chamber so
go ahead keep publishing whatever you
want obviously it's from 2019 but I
think more importantly is the statement
this makes which is the president saying
I'm sick of this and guess what I have
endless bankroll for this so you guys
can use your your bank to try to defend
it why do you think the times would run
a fake column like that one I don't I
don't know it's it's like you and I have
different opinions on many issues I
don't say that your opinions fake I just
say it's an opinion Jesse and I think
this is an opinion this is a frivolous
lawsuit
I mean it's intended to intimidate the
press and intimidate people and maybe
it's red meat for the base but I think
it's really low-grade red meat
and I got an opinion be wrong your acts
are wrong look if if their facts are
wrong it's like I'm saying again the New
York Times this is not a news article
this is an opinion piece you know what
I'm reminded of at the moment there's
great pressure on the Wall Street
Journal because they ran an opinion
piece that the Chinese government didn't
like and they threw the Chinese that the
Wall Street Journal reporters out of the
country this is an intimidation tactic
Wall Street Journal shouldn't back down
I don't report he's just making them
burn money on yeah lawyer fees but it
helps him because he can he wants to
push back he wants to punch back so
they're like okay well we could try this
and you might not win in court but you
know what we could try it and then he
gets a lot of publicity about it now
we're talking about it again and but
here's the other thing I think it also
helps in New York Times
there are subscriptions have gone up and
up and up everybody in media has been
doing better during a print a trump
presidency so now they get to close
ranks and let all their subscribers you
know think they'll think twice about
running small stuff no I do not know
well I also I think that they'll find a
way to protect their opinion writers
okay yeah correct
problem is though their opinion writers
also report I mean I find their opinions
on the front page you know what I mean
it's I mean they can say that this one
was on the compet but I when a news
reporter writes analysis on the front
page how are you supposed to yeah yeah
and I you know I don't want to be sued
when I'm wrong but then again but
generally I always admit that I'm wrong
oh I admit that I'm wrong on everything
it's actually really feels good and
maybe if these people admit they're
wrong he dropped the suit however what
sparked this whole thing is probably the
biggest story in the media world which
was the Covington case I mean the
coveted case encapsulated all of the
very bad elements of media instincts and
bias
you know this the Covington story began
with that guy looks bad that other guy
looks good this story gets me
emotionally excited and my story might
catch fire on social media so that was
what that's what how that story rolled
and it resulted in a lawsuit that they
had to settle and I think that has
changed the way people look at the media
that they can fight back but I might say
isn't it ironic that Republicans who
were normally opposed to this kind of
lawsuit you know digging digging up
lawsuits on people now oh yeah go ride
it and I think when people don't think
it's frivolous well